so i get i get the streak
early on that's a good thing usually in
this tournament
i'm about um
i'm about 20 minutes from joining at
this point so that's already a
very promising start for me oh it's just
he's just uh this [ __ ] doesn't work does
it
because there's usually 20 minutes of
technical problems and then you join
uh yeah some tech tech problems and also
for some reason i'm usually uh other
reasons i'm late to the party
so this is obviously
obviously a lot better and here i'm a
pawn down
for i would say a little bit now i'm no
longer upon down since i win on c4
and now i'm obviously completely
completely fine we'll take the bishop
pair that you so
nicely offer me sir
it's not gonna be easy to win but
hopefully i can play fast enough to
play on time as well we're just gonna
take this one i think
don't know if it's objectively winning
but um
okay now the funnily enough the
uh the bishop on a2 is not trapped and
his bishop was
um so now this is just not c4
immediately
and then we run and we take
don't pre-move there unnecessarily and
then
okay and let those was a nice trick
uh king h8 oh
no it wasn't i thought it was stalemate
if
it's not paid yeah it's not paid okay
then
i take it back